Prof: This is data from
Bolivia.
It came out the end of last
year and it's from the year
2003.
Demographic data is always
delayed because it takes a long
time to collect it,
and analyze it,
and so forth.
This is a fairly standard thing
that's happening.
This is various five year
bunches, they take these surveys
every five years,
this is from a thing called The
Demographic and Health Surveys
which are done basically in
every developing country of the
world by their own statistical
service.
Every country has a fairly
decent census and statistical
service and they go and ask
either all the women,
if it's a census year,
or a subset of the women if
it's not a census year and they
ask all kinds of questions,
some of which you will see.
The first thing of course is
how many children do you have?
They used--when they started
these kind of surveys they used
to ask men and they would get a
number, the husband.
Then they'd ask the wife,
get a different number,
and when they checked it turns
out the woman was right and the
man had no clue.
Veena will tell you,
maybe some stories about it's
not even a simple question,
even to the woman how many
children have you had.
In a lot of ways,
men's data was unreliable and
in the early days they really
were interested in getting a
real ground--
they didn't know how many
people there were in the world,
what the fertility rates were,
how fast population was
growing,
so just to get the basic ideas,
women were asked.
From that date on men have
somewhat been excluded from the
data collection,
so a lot of what we know,
in fact almost all of what we
know is about women,
but nowadays its changing.
In the last number of year's
people realize it takes two to
tango and men are starting to
come more into the picture.
Anyway here by 19--so this is a
five-year age group and this is
the total fertility rate.
In 1965 and 1970 and other
years they were having roughly
6.6 children,
then gradually every five-year
increment it came down until the
most recent number is 3.8
children.
Now keep that 3.8 number in
mind because we want to compare
that to some other things,
and you probably know a little
about Bolivia.
It's totally Catholic,
it's quite poor,
it's mostly agricultural,
it's not very urbanized,
education is at a fairly low
level,
and the status of women there
is not really wonderful.
With all those indicate--what
they call social indicators what
would you think about the
fertility desires of women in
Bolivia?
High? Low?
High.
All of those are sort of
standard classical factors that
would make you think that they
want a lot of children,
but when you look at the actual
data it's rather moderate.
It's still very high by our
standards of one or two children
but still--
and it's still important for
the world because at 3.8 you
double the population almost
every--
not quite double it every
generation so this is quite
high,
but it's nothing like a 6,7
child thing or in the past the
traditional number of 7 or 8,
or maybe 9 children per woman,
so it's a situation of moderate
fertility.
Now what--the next kind of set
of questions is well this is the
number of children you're
having, how many do you want?
They asked--this is asked--it's
a very tricky kind of question
as you'll probably hear so
there's a lot of different ways
of spinning this question.
The first is they ask you,
'did you want your last child?'
That has a whole complicated
set of answers and just look out
here for the total numbers that
'did you want the child at the
time that you had it?'
Well 38% of women said,
yes I wanted it when I had it,
but not wanted at all,
somewhat larger 40% of women
didn't want it at all.
That's a surprising split and
then in between there's another
20% of women who gave a more
ambiguous answer,
'well I didn't really want the
child right then but I probably
would have wanted a child in the
future,' and a lot of guess work
on the part of the respondent in
that about what their future
desires will be.
As you know,
humans change their mind every
five minutes on important
topics,
but that's a very interesting
statistic that there's more
children unwanted than are
wanted and that's somewhere in
between.
Now there's probably a lot of
bias in this data.
This is not considered
wonderful data because you're
asking a woman who's just had a
child, or fairly recently had a
child, did you want that child?
What's the bias?
You say yes.
I mean it's very--you have to
really not like that child in
order to say,
'oh yeah I had him but I didn't
want him.'
It happens and you see that at
40% of women do say that,
but this data is probably
biased to put more kids in this
category then what the woman
really feels,
although again,
intentions are very changeable
and attitudes toward other
people,
husbands, children,
one minute you love them and
the next minute hate them and so
forth,
so that's problematic,
the data there.
One way of getting around that
particular problem is to ask
them,
'do you want another child in
the future' because that's more
volitional,
that's not saying I did
something wrong or something
that I didn't want and so here's
that set of data;
again all this from the
Demographic and Health Survey.
Again it's sort of what you
would expect,
this is women who don't want,
want to stop childbearing,
don't want any more children.
If they've had no children
already very few of them don't
want any children 6.5%.
If they've had one child
already 30% say one child is
enough, I'm ready to stop.
If they had two children you're
up to 2/3 of the women now say
that's enough for me,
I want to stop and when you get
to three you're almost at the
maximum,
and then four and above you're
into the 91%-92%.
You notice it's kind of
interesting that it rises and
then it stays flat,
so there's about 8% of women
who no matter how many children
they have they always say 'no I
want more,
I don't want to stop.'
This is what we call very
traditional women,
that as many as God gives me,
here comes in one version or
another,
but it's 8% it's a very small
number,
women who don't seem to have an
idea of some number at which
they want to stop,
or some of them they've already
had whether they want to now
stop.
Now you can ask another kind of
question,
you say this is called an ideal
number of children,
and you ask a question like,
if you could go back to the
beginning before you had any
children,
how many children would you
have wanted as your ideal
number?
You get these kinds of numbers
that women who have no children
want to have two--who now have
no children asking what they
think their ideal was;
they want 2.1 children.
Women who already have one
child 2.1, those that have two
say 2.4, and then the number
goes on up, including women who
have six or more children.
Now it's pretty clear that one
should really expect this kind
of thing because the simplest,
most obvious reason is,
women who want more children
have more children.
As you have more children
that's a sign that you wanted
more children.
That certainly may be the
biggest factor,
just a very simple kind of
thing.
Another factor is women who
have had more children are
older.
Remember we're talking about a
period in history,
I mean this is recent,
where ideas are changing,
fertility is changing,
standards and norms and
personal desires are changing,
so the older women just by the
age factor will probably be of a
somewhat older generation.
I won't go into it but this
looks at that,
here is the age of a woman and
again,
how many if you went back to
the beginning,
how many children would you
have liked and you get just an
age factor,
but not wildly different from
this.
Just generational change is a
bigger factor in that then you
might expect.
And also in this rise is what
we've just talked about that
women already had a bunch of
children,
when they reconstruct back what
they used to think or now think
that they would think they--
again well I have three I'm
either happy or whatever they
think about it,
it's hard for them to say no I
don't want this many.
Have you noticed anything funny
now?
Anything about the number,
these numbers and the number I
told you to remember?
No class of woman wants more
than 3.3 children.
Most of the women are in the
two range and only those that
have six and more children want
3.3,
and the same if you look it out
by age,
no group of women wants more
than three.
What did I say about how many
they're having?
3.8.
This now accords with the other
stuff that you've seen that
women want--it looks like women
want fewer children than they're
having.
Well this is Bolivia,
maybe there's something a
little bit special about
Bolivia,
and you always have to check
and see whether you're getting
some sort of outlier or is this
the general situation.
You don't have to look at that
too closely yet.
An economist at The World Bank,
a guy named Lant Pritchett,
did a paper and the first thing
he did was collect all that data
from every country.
These Demographic and Health
Surveys are published every time
a country does its own
statistical demographic survey,
and so all of this information
is available,
and now it's computerized and
so forth,
and there's uniformity.
There's a group called Macro
International that sort of helps
these various countries design
these surveys so that they can
be compared internationally and
get fairly good comparability of
the data.
What he did is,
of these various statistical
ways of finding out how many
children women want and they
have different numbers.
This is average ideal number of
children,
this is desired total fertility
rate,
and here's a third one,
the wanted total fertility rate
and they all correct for
different factors in different
ways,
but the only thing I think that
you have to sort of notice is
that they're all about the same.
No matter how you spin this you
get a picture that looks
something like this.
What is it?
Wanted TFR, in this case is how
many children does the woman
want?
Self report,
this is how many she says she
wants, do you want 2,3,
4,5, 6,7, 8 and this is the
total fertility rate.
How many children is she
actually having?
The countries are luckily all
named here, and you can see
Syria for instance,
the women want 5 children and
they're having 7.
something children.
Here is--pick another one,
Pakistan, they want 4 children
they're having 6 children.
You can look at that and every
country is in there.
One important thing is how
important the desire,
whatever children want,
that there's a very strong
correlation between the number
of children that you want and
the number of children you
actually have,
aggregated by country.
I mean we're taking a lot of
people and lumping them into two
numbers,
this number and this number,
and there's great variation of
course within in each country
but that's certainly an
important factor.
The key line,
because Pritchett in gathering
this data, wanted to make a
different point which we're not
going to get to today.
He leaves out a really
important line here which is
this line that I've drawn this
in.
What line is that?
That's the line where it is if
you want two children you have
two children,
if you want three children you
have three children,
if you want nine children you
have nine children,
so any country that was on that
line people are having the
number of children that they
want.
What do you notice about all
these countries?
Every single one of them is
above the line,
meaning that in every single
country they're having more
children then they want.
What they want is what they
have;
they're all above that line of
equality.
This is some of the cleanest
social science data I have ever
seen,
the way they're all one side of
the line,
they follow very nicely the
regression line.
This is the regression line
that he drew in which is just a
line that is closest to all the
points together,
a statistical way of making the
line as close as possible to all
of the points.
This gap here between what
people want, if they got what
they wanted and what they're
actually having is called unmet
need.
A very complicated idea,
much argued about,
and Veena may or may not
discuss it,
but what it tells you is that
there's a very noticeable
difference between--
it's describing that difference
between the number of children
people have and what they want.
It's roughly one child per
family here.
This number in principle should
be one and a half children,
but there's certain
connections, it's actually about
one child per family;
the difference between what
they have and what they want.
Now in the developing world
this is a little bit old data,
but in the developing world
today the average fertility rate
is about 3.5.
In order to come to stable
population in the developing
world it has to come down to
2.1,
but if all the women here in
these countries that are
reporting what they want,
if they actually had the number
of children that they want you'd
subtract out from the 3.5 (one
child),
you're down to 2.5 and you're
actually very close then to
what's called replacement level
fertility this 2.1 children.
This difference of what women
want and what they have is an
extremely important issue.
In one version of the kind of
thing that Planned Parenthood
and other international and
domestic organizations do is
help women get to the fertility
that they want.
Not as pushing them into
something but giving them
something that they already
want.
This data, as in all data,
brings up a whole bunch of
questions.
One: does this really reflect
people's data?
Have we actually--have these
kinds of questions and this kind
of statistical analysis really
tapped into the real emotions
and feelings of the people?
You always have to question
these kinds of survey data.
You remember that you read this
in readings in Africa,
that when the women were asked
how many children do you want,
it was a meaningless question
to them.
They said whatever Ala says,
whatever God says,
they can't--it's just not in
their--what their technical term
is 'calculus of rational
choice.'
Well there's women like that in
this survey and what number do
you put down for them?
These women,
as I've said is basically--is
all collected from women.
What about men,
do men want more children?
Do they want the same?
Do they want less?
Is it that women's desires
don't matter?
It is men's desires that really
matter?
Why do women up here in Kenya
and Mali at this time want so
many children and have so many
children?
Whereas, countries you might
not think of wildly different
Trinidad, Dominican Republic,
Fiji, various other places are
way down here.
Why some countries here and
some countries there?
Another thing is that in most
of the world people actually
know about contraception.
Here is data again from the
Bolivian survey 2003 and do they
know a method of contraception?
Well they know any method yeah,
95% of the women know about
contraception,
and even the modern methods
which are listed here,
92% of the women they know
about it and many of the women
know about more than one method,
so 80% know about the pill,
another 80% the IUD,
another 80% the injectables.
That means there's a lot of
overlap between these.
They don't know one method,
they know two,
and three, and male condom they
know about, female sterilization
they know about and so on.
This is lactational amenorrhea
which is the traditional method
that we've talked about of
spacing births and half the
women know that if you
breastfeed you'll prolong the
interval between your births.
Not only do they know about the
method but they've used the
method,
77% of women have tried
something, a fair amount of that
is 20% of these women are using
only traditional methods which
include rhythm type methods,
but still 57% have actually
used a modern method.
Currently using drops down.
They've tried it and for some
reason they've stopped.
One is this medical problem
that the dominant reason why
women say they're not using
contraception--
so you've seen the data,
they want to stop childbearing,
it's overwhelming.
You saw like Bolivia--what was
the final number,
I don't know I pointed it out,
70% I think it was--
something like 70% of the women
say ‘I don't want any more
children ever,
I want to just plain old stop,'
and then if you add in those
that are not sure about the
future,
but they say well at least not
in the next two years and then
beyond two years I don't know so
you add at least another 10%--
something like 80% of women
want some kind of protection,
they either want to mostly stop
totally or at least for the next
two years.
You can even go down,
this is again older data from
Bolivia, that's one of my
favorite places;
I was--spent some good times
there.
If you just take teenagers age
15 to 19 already about 40% of
them say I've had all the
children I want the whole rest
of my life and the average age
of that sample is 17 years old.
So you have these huge number
of women who don't want--
want to stop childbearing and
yet if you look from the
Demographic and Health Surveys
at the contraceptive prevalence,
like in Bolivia again,
at the time of Robey article
that you have read last night or
are going to read,
the women who want protection
either--
are about--were about 80% and
the women that were using
protection was like 12%,
and you ask them why and
largely, and especially more
recently,
it's medical reasons.
There is first of all a
campaign by conservative,
especially religious people in
places like Kenya to--
they're opposed to the use of
contraception and they really
blow up medical problems,
so the people are getting very
poor information on it.
Now here's an example,
one of the undergraduates that
took this course a few years
back,
a very energetic young lady and
she got interested in this stuff
and so I arranged for her to go
to Kenya to answer exactly this
question.
Why is it that women--and
you'll hear a little later--
why is it that women who say
they don't want any children,
they're living in Nairobi and
there's plenty of contraceptives
available in Nairobi and you can
get them more or less free,
or a small cost,
and they're not using it,
then they get pregnant.
They can't have that baby,
they don't want the baby,
so they go to some bush doctor,
and it's illegal in most of
Africa,
Sub-Saharan Africa,
all of Africa,
abortion is illegal but here
they got pregnant so they go to
some horrible clinic.
The death rate is very,
very high.
Here's women who don't want
children,
don't use contraception even
though it's available to them,
and yet when they get pregnant
they're willing to undergo an
operation,
a very crude,
illegal operation by an
untrained practitioner that will
lead to a very high rate of
death and they're well aware of
that fate.
Everybody knows somebody who's
died from a botched abortion and
you've read some of that in the
European--
in the era in America and
Europe when that was common.
She went there and it turns out
that women are very much
influenced by rumors,
what they hear,
because their education is not
really their thing.
This student,
this Yale undergraduate
collected these rumors,
and one of the rumors,
one of the most extreme rumors
was well mostly in Africa,
and I think you read this--the
people that haven't been to
university don't distinguish
between stomach and uterus,
it's all one big cavity.
Was that in one of your
readings?
I think it was,
anyway it doesn't matter;
it's all one thing there.
Now you take a pill,
and they know something about
pills,
penicillin and everything,
but every day for the rest of
my life,
why do I have to keep taking
this pill?
Why don't I take a pill and
that settles the issue?
Well they figure I get pregnant
and the fetus starts to grow
inside me.
Well what does the pill do?
The pill goes down and
dissolves, they have some idea
that it's wet and dissolves,
and then reforms over the fetus
and starts coating it.
But everyday they know the
fetus is getting bigger,
so you need to take another
pill to add to the coat of it,
and at the end what you grow
and what you get is a mummy.
You get a fetus that can be
fully grown and coated with a
white stuff like an egg and
that's what you deliver.
Well if you believe something
like that you're not going to go
anywhere near pills,
right?
Some of these similar kinds of
stories happen with everything
else.
This young lady herself got the
five little silastic implants in
her arm and she when she came
back she was very--
she got it in Kenya,
one because she wanted it and
two she wanted to show the women
sees it's not dangerous,
I'm even doing it myself,
but that's irrelevant.
One thing is--any--no clue
about medical stuff,
physiology, digestion,
anatomy inside,
huge numbers of women don't
have any clue about this.
This girl did a very clever
thing, she was a Yalie,
and she then asked the
women--Kenyan women are not any
stupider than anybody else,
they're smart women,
they said do you believe such a
rumor?
They were just reporting it as
a rumor and the women were of
course very skeptical of this.
Well I've heard this and that
is it true or not and they were
properly skeptical of it.
She collected this whole range
of rumors,
and she found that--she asked,
which ones do you believe more
than others,
and she sort of could get a
ranking on it,
and then she asked all kinds of
questions and it turned out that
it was very simple,
that they believed something
depending on how many times they
had heard it.
This particular rumor was not
one of the most prevalent,
some other rumors were,
equally not true,
but if you hear it a lot then
you believe it because they
don't have a sense of expertise,
scientific competency,
any of that sort of stuff.
A sociologist at Penn,
Susan Watkins,
who I may have mentioned before
and certainly will mention again
who works in Kenya in the Luo
region,
not in Nairobi,
a different region,
she attended a lecture where a
local woman,
speaking the local dialect had
gone to Nairobi and gotten
trained--
a nurse type--she wasn't
trained--an official nurse--
but working in that kind of
establishment,
went to Nairobi and got trained
to be a reproductive health
educator.
She comes back and is having
some sort of a white coat or
uniform,
or a blouse or something and
she gives a lecture to the women
with--
they have these models of
pregnancy models,
models of internal anatomy
slides, very nice and she was
good at it,
and the women were absolutely
rapt,
they were listening to every
word.
But as they left the room they
started sort of staring each
other,
what are we going to make out
of this,
and outside there was a woman
scrubbing the floor,
a washer woman there and these
women just dove onto the washer
woman and said,
is she telling--is what she's
telling is true,
is this good for us,
is she our kind of women that
the--
and really asked the washer
woman all kinds of questions
about this information which the
washer woman had no technical
expertise.
The idea being that they don't
have this sense of that
knowledge comes from some sort
of expertise,
that more knowledge comes from
someone like me is a more
important variable than that
you've been to Nairobi and
gotten some kind of training.
And the washer woman they
perceived was closer to them
than the woman who has gotten
some education even though it
was a local--
a person from that local
community.
It's a very complicated issue
and the big battle is in getting
people thinking about this and
trying to do some of that,
is sort of how much of this
difference and how much of the--
people in general having
more--how much of it is that
there's something wrong this
data that they really do want a
lot of children and many of
them--
in many countries up there they
wanted 5,6, 7,8 children and how
much of it is--
they don't have access--access
doesn't mean just handing out
condoms.
This is the last story and I'll
shut up.
There's a famous story that
passes around family planning
circles about someone going into
an African village,
and finding in front of each
hut a stick and the stick was an
unrolled condom.
That was very strange and so
they went and asked what this
is?
We had a family planning worker
and they showed us how to
prevent pregnancy and they had
this stick and they showed us
how to unroll it and they did
that.
I have heard this kind of story
any number of times and I tossed
it off--
it's something like--I had a
little--
the--more doubts,
I just tossed the story off.
Then I'm in Kline Tower and I
came out one night,
I work late,
and the Forestry was having a
party and some of the graduate
students were out back smoking
or chatting,
so I chatted them up and one of
them had been in a part of South
Africa called Transkei,
and she told me she went into
this village and what did she
see?
It was cucumbers and all the
people had cucumbers with
condoms unrolled on them,
so this is a student who's here
at Yale right now that saw this
with her own eyes,
so this is another one of these
amazing stories that's true and
gives you sort of at least an
anecdotal hint into what's going
on--
scratching beneath this data.
Okay see you next week.